who are doing such vital work to remind
us of our moral obligation to future
generations
but look as i said yesterday
it's not just a moral imperative it's an
economic imperative as well
investing in our clean energy future is
an enormous opportunity
enormous opportunity for every country
to create good-paying jobs
and spur a broad-based economic recovery
as i've said you've heard me say before
my colleagues as well
when i think of climate crisis i think
of jobs
and that's what the buildback better
framework will do for the american
people it's going to bring historic
investment in clean energy addressing
the climate crisis it's going to cut
greenhouse gas emissions by well over
a gigaton by 2030 it's going to save
consumers money and their energy bills
and with tax credits for things like
installing solar panels and
weatherization of their homes
it's also going to provide manufacturing
credits to make sure the united states
is competing in energy markets the
future like solar panels and wind
turbines
it's also going to accelerate electric
vehicles and electric school buses and
build a nationwide network of 500 000
charging stations to power them it's
about jobs it's about competitiveness
versus complacency it's about making the
world safer cleaner healthier a place
for our children and children all around
the world to look to the future in a way
that they can't now
i
and so there's so many other things that
have happened today that i feel good
about
uh but uh let me um uh
start if you will by i'll be happy to
take your your
your questions uh
phil you got a question
i watch you on tv a lot
thank you very much mr president
uh you know your disappointment with
chinese actions on climate in rome and
also
the lack of willingness for chinese
president xi jinping to show up at
either the g20 or cop26 but i wanted to
ask more broadly when you assess where
things stand right now in u.s china
relationships after your first 10 months
in office your diplomats have had
difficulty engaging in a substantive
manner with some of their counterparts
you have a chinese military that has
tested a hypersonic missile this summer
it is building its nuclear capability
what is your general assessment of where
things stand and are you concerned that
the potential for armed conflict has
grown over the course of your first 10
months in office well
let me start off by addressing the first
part of not the question the statement
and that is that i indicated that china
and russia not showing up in saudi
arabia as a problem
we showed up
and by showing up we've had a profound
impact on the way i think the rest of
the world is looking at the united
states in this leadership role
i think it's been a big mistake quite
frankly for
china with respect to china not showing
up the rest of the world going to look
to china and say what value added are
they
are they providing and they've lost an
ability to influence people around the
world and all the people here at cop
the same way i would argue with regard
to russia
with regard to the more profound
question about do am i worried about an
armed conflict or some that accidentally
occurring with china
no i'm not but i have had as i've said
before and i think we've talked about
this film but i may be mistaken
uh that um uh
i think
as i've said
i look at china and i've had hours of
conversations with xi jinping
both in person when i was vice president
and since i've been president at least
five or six hours worth of conversations
on the telephone
and i'm going to be having a virtual
summit with him
uh i've made it clear
this does this is competition it does
not have to be conflict
there is no reason there need be
conflict but i've also indicated to him
and i've so i don't i'm not reluctant to
say it publicly that uh we expect him to
play by the rules of the road
we're not going to change our attitude
toward constitutional international
airspace international sea lanes etc we
also made it clear that
we have to work on dealing with things
like cyber security and a whole range of
other issues
but i
i'm not looking for i don't anticipate
there will be a need for uh
to be there be physical conflict
but you know as you've heard me say this
before
my dad had an expression you say the
only conflict worse than one that's
intended is one that's unintended
one that's unintended and so in my
meetings with him virtually coming up i
might haven't set the exact date yet i
want to make sure there's no
misunderstanding
it's competition not conflict and
so there's no
no unintended
yep peter
mr president you're touting on this
visit your 1.75 trillion dollar plan
that includes climate but your party is
still not united behind it senator joe
manchin yesterday called it budget
gimmicks shell games and a recipe for
economic crisis today he said he never
signed off
on the framework so do you have a
specific commitment from senator manchin
to support your build back better bill
yes or no and how do you respond to
those criticisms and i have a quick
follow-up
number one i'm not going to talk about
the specifics of my conversations he
will vote for this if we have
in this proposal
what he has anticipated and that is
looking at the fine print and the detail
of what comes out of the house in terms
of the actual legislative initiatives i
believe
that joe will be there with regard to
the issue of whether or not he thinks
that he's worried about
this being inflationary or going to be
negative impact in the economy
i think that uh i've made it clear to
joe and we'll continue to and we will
that
as i've apologized and repeated peter
but
17 nobel laureates on economics said
it's going to lower inflation
raise wages increase competition create
two million jobs a year etc and so i
think that
i understand that joe was looking
for the precise detail to make sure
nothing got
slipped in in terms of the way in which
the legislation got written that is
different than he
acknowledged he would agree to but i
think we'll get this done
you mentioned the word inflation there
you recently said you have no short-term
answer to bring down gas prices but as
you know it's not just gas prices now
rents are up the cost of everyday items
are up inflation in the u.s is at a
13-year high so when specifically should
americans expect those prices to come
down
well look um
first of all
the significant reason why prices are up
is because of covet affecting the supply
chain
i mean i know i'm not trying to be
instructor i know you know this
number one number two
um
if you take a look at uh
you know gas prices and you take a look
at uh oil prices
that is a consequence of
thus far
the refusal of
of russia or
or the opec nations to
pump more oil
and we'll see what happens on that score
uh sooner than later um
number three i think if you take a look
at what we're talking about you look for
this coming thanksgiving you know uh
we're in a situation where we find that
uh
um
we are in a very different circumstance
last thanksgiving uh
um you know i uh
uh
as i said this year we're working on a
supply chain issue but last thanksgiving
i sat down with my wife
my daughter and my son-in-law
this thanksgiving we're all in a very
different circumstance
things are a hell of a lot better
and
the wages have gone up higher faster
than inflation
and we have generated real economic
growth
it doesn't mean these dislocations
aren't real they do affect people's
lives for example one of the reasons why
i decided to talk about the need to deal
with
the uh the operation and the gouging
that occurs in some of the
pricing of beef and chicken and other
things is that
that's why i think
that's why i indicated to you we're
going to look at whether or not
there's a violation of of antitrust laws
and what they're doing so there's a lot
to look at but the bottom line is that i
think
that
anyone who would prefer
as bad as things are in terms of prices
helping
hurting families now trade this
thanksgiving for last thanksgiving
um
jan epstein wall street journal
i mean excuse me
i beg your pardon bloomberg i hope i i i
got it i got it thank you especially
since my granddaughter works for you
guys
in a different circumstance so i
got it i'm in trouble well i'm going to
ask a very bloomberg question to begin
which is um have you decided who you
will nominate to chair the federal
reserve board and if not can you speak a
little bit about what you're thinking
about as you consider your choice for
fed chair and the other seats that are
open
this is the latest that that a president
has gone without nominating somebody
the year before a nominee needs to be
selected and are you concerned
about potentially having a short
timeline especially if you're not going
to re-nominate jay powell
no no no
no i'm not going to discuss it with you
because that's in train now we'll be
making those announcements fairly
quickly
it's been in train for some time
number one
number two
i also would indicate that
i think we're going to have plenty of
time to make sure all the major nominees
are able to be cleared in time
that where their terms would expire
and number three i've given a lot of
thought to it and i've been meeting with
my economic advisors on what the best
choices are we've got a lot of good
choices but i'm not going to speculate
now
[Music]
nancy cbs
i think you had your hand up i'm sorry
did you
thank you very much mr president
some of the commitments you made here
won't happen unless
congress passes future legislation how
do you convince republicans and even
some democrats to get behind more
spending if they look at this conference
and say
china isn't
meeting these global goals russia
doesn't intend to meet these global
goals india doesn't plan to why should
we
because we want to be able to breathe
and we want to be able to lead the world
look i mean it sincerely
i think presumptuous to me to say talk
for another leader
but the fact that china
trying to assert
understandably
a new role in the world as a world
leader
not showing up
come on
the single most important thing that's
gotten the attention of the world
is climate
everywhere
from iceland to uh
to australia too you know i mean it just
is a gigantic issue
and they've walked away
how do you do that and claim to be able
to have any leadership mantle the same
with putin and russia you know
his tundra is burning he's in a circum
literally the tongue is burning he has
serious serious climate problems
and he is a mum on the willingness to do
anything and so i i genuinely believe
and i mean this in the bottom of my
heart
when i said at cop 7 excuse me at the g7
that america was back
um you know people wondered whether well
is that really true well we were able to
change the dynamic of a lot of things
coming out of the g7
i think i i
it's gonna what i'm about to say sounds
awfully self-serve
two world leaders came up to me today
and said thank you for your leadership
you're making a big difference here
you're moving people
uh
i think you and i talked about that john
with one of the folks talking to us
and so uh i think the fact that america
showed up
america showed up and decided to lead
and laid out clearly what it wished to
do for example
you know as i said the mere fact that
we were able to you know go from
uh
seven or eight people or countries
talking about uh maybe is it is 14 i
don't remember the original number
to deal with the whole notion of
of uh methane
you know now a hundred nations have
signed on
a hundred nations
a hundred nations have signed on to
reduce methane by 30 percent by 30 30.
that is and methane is 25 times more
toxic to the environment than co2
so we're making real progress or the
deforestation issue look what we're
doing look what we've been able to put
together
in addition to that one of the things
that i feel
the best about and i don't claim
uniquely any unique credit for it but i
think that we've gotten for the first
time
a combination of in dealing with
international problem and that of that
circumstances affect all nations
that we've not only gotten
countries off the sideline in terms of
making significant financial
contributions but literally literally
trillions of dollars worth of the
private sector jumping in knowing
they've got to play and they're going to
play an incredibly
positive part in dealing with these
problems
it's real
it's genuine and so
i i just think that
you know that old bad expression the
proof of the pudding's in the eating uh
you know i i feel confident we're going
to get done we have to do at home in
order to deliver
and lastly you know
if you take a look at what what economy
is growing
the united states
it's growing it has problems
mainly because of covenant supply chain
but it's growing we've created over six
million jobs we're leading the world in
terms of the fastest growing economy
major economies
so i i think you know we're going
through a difficult time
in the world because of
covet because of supply chain
consequences because of the environment
and all that's occurred the way it's in
fact imploded in the near term
but i as i said to you earlier and i
really mean it um
i i think it presents a gigantic
opportunity
an opportunity
to a sense press the restart button
and move in a direction that i think the
vast majority of countries and look i'm
sure you you interview other world
leaders that are here the vast majority
think this is an opportunity i'm not
quite sure
exactly what to do exactly how to do it
not that i have all the answers i'm not
implying that but they know that they
know that growth rests in
dealing with the economy in a way that
affects
the whole notion of what we're going to
do about
climate change and it's a gigantic
opportunity
okay
i i called on the wall street journal
catherine i got the wrong one sorry
let's try the real wall street journal
thank you very much we are the real wall
street journal uh mr president you
tweeted earlier asking virginia and new
jersey residents to vote uh democrat
terry mcauliffe is struggling in a state
that you won by 10 points do you see do
you see his problems as a rebuke of your
presidency and could this signal your
real losses for democrats in the
midterms
we're going to win
i think we're going to win in virginia
and you know you're reporting it being
close
the race is very close
it's about who shows up who turns out
and granted i did win by a large margin
but the point of the matter is that i
think that this is this is going to be
we all knew from the beginning it's
going to be a tight race
and it is tight this could get down to
turnout and it's gonna my guess is i'm
gonna be uh
landing at one o'clock in the morning
east coast time that's probably about
the time we'll be hearing what the final
results are i think we're gonna win new
jersey as well
but look you know the uh
the off year
uh is is is always unpredictable
especially when we don't have a general
election going on at the same time
that's been the case
up and down
you know for a long time especially as
virginia's turned more and more blue
but having said that
i
i don't believe and i've not seen any
evidence that
whether or not i am doing well or poorly
whether or not i've got my agenda passed
or not
is going to have any real impact on when
you're losing even if we had passed my
agenda i wouldn't claim we won because
biden's agenda passed so uh but i think
it's a i i i think it's going to be very
close
i think it's going to get down to as you
all know
turn out
and i think that based on what i have
heard so far
um it's awful hard for me to be
prognosticating which i don't like doing
as president anyway from overseas but
but i think i i hope
that every eligible voter in virginia
and new jersey shows up and votes
and the more of the due the better off i
think our chances are and i think i
think we're gonna i think we're gonna
win
okay
all right
npr
scott
okay um you mentioned climate activists
before and i want to ask something about
them your touting agreements other world
leaders have tattered agreements but the
atmosphere around the conference here
is skeptical and it's pretty angry
uh climate activists feel like decades
and decades of cops have led to broken
promises and they feel like even if all
of these goals are reached that you're
talking about the last few days
it's just not enough right now and i'm
wondering what you would say to the
people outside who are really angry at
this conference especially at this
moment where joe manchin has expressed
you know has created more doubt that
your climate legislation will pass and
you've got a very conservative supreme
court about to take a look at whether
your epa can regulate greenhouse gas
emissions what's your message to people
outside who just worry this all isn't
enough right now given the crisis well
first of all um i think anyone
who is uh focused on the environment
should be worried we've got a lot more
to do beyond what we've done
we've done more than we've ever done
though that's the point
and more has to be done and
i i don't find i didn't have
a single member of the this
conference come up to me and say
are you going to pass what you have and
what do you think is how's that going to
affect it what are you going to do
what they're looking at is what in fact
has happened in terms of everything from
dealing with deforestation to what we're
going to do on
buildback better and how we've
been able to focus now i mean when's the
last time you heard world leaders sit
down together and agree
that what they're going to do is when
they deal with the needs of the
infrastructure of other countries that
they're going to
focus first and foremost on whether or
not what the what the climatic what
the climate impact is on that
so i think look this is a
uh there
there's a reason
for people
to be worried
i'm worried i'm worried if we don't
continue to move forward and make the
kind of progress we're now making that
it's gonna i mean we we throw into
jeopardy the prospect that we're gonna
be able to keep the temperature from
rising above 1.5 degrees celsius
but i'm optimistic because i think
there's a
how can i say it i guess maybe the best
way to say it to scott
is
what i feel is
that
the populations
of each of our countries
have a different perspective than they
did at cop 25.
i think there is i mean
not because of necessarily any of the
leaders of any of our countries
including mine
that all of a sudden people are seeing
these things happening they never
thought would happen
you're seeing people drown in their
basements in queens new york because of
flooding and rain
they're seeing that you know
more territory burned down in the united
states just since the first of the year
then it makes up the entire landmass of
the state of new jersey they've seen
hurricane with a hundred and top winds
of
178 miles an hour i mean
so they're looking at these things
they're seeing more the water's warming
they're seeing a whole range of things
occurring
around the world that haven't happened
and it's sort of like whoa
whoa because i don't get what i used to
get when i started to i don't there's no
reason why anyone remember this
but back when a fine republican a guy
named dick lugar
was from from the state of indiana and
he and i were either the chairman or
ranking members of the foreign relations
committee
this over 20 years ago we ended up
proposing and it worked but it got no
enthusiasm a thing for
debt for nature swaps
people looked at us like what the hell
are you doing why are you forgiving the
debt so brazil won't you know burn down
more of the forest why are you doing
that so they will do
now
everybody goes whoa
what else can you do
so i think there's a whole different
attitude that's out there and i think
this is being led and i'm not being
solicitous here i think this is being
led by uh
you know uh
my granddaughters and their friends that
generation i think they're out there
going whoa
and they're having a profound impact
having a proud impact on their parents
and their grandparents about what's
happening
and then all these climactic and
climactic things have happened
that they that people are now paying
attention like they never did before so
you know there's a lot more to do
and it's going to determine whether or
not
we're going to be able to fund what
we're talking about
but for example
even if the funding didn't come from
some of the governments
you have the private sector now engaged
where they're talking about investing
literally the need to invest over
trillions of dollars off the sidelines
it's bankers that are now deciding they
gotta i talked a long time ago with you
all about that you have major corporate
america pricing in the price of carbon
it matters
so things are changing we just have half
the right stewardship and enough sense
as world leaders to get it right so
thank you all so very much appreciate it
foreign
i